so i'm gonna ask you a question that has
nothing to do with loki first just to
get it out of the way because
i'm a huge fan of wedding crashers and i
heard that
there's a script for the sequel that
maybe you guys have read
so i'm curious what did you think of
reading the script
yeah there is a script and david dobkin
has
who directed of course the first one has
been working on it
and uh we've been talking about it and
uh it's been nice talking to vince
um and it's one of those movies that you
know really
you know seem to connect with people so
if if we can come up with a
um you know something we think could be
great then uh
then i'm sure we'll do it there's a lot
of rumors you guys might be filming it
this year
do you think it's actually gonna happen
i i someone said august and i don't see
that happening
um but um i think it's you know
before anything it was sort of you know
making sure that
everybody felt we had um a great story
i have a question from someone named
michael waldron
maybe you've heard of him yes um and he
asks
in armageddon why couldn't your
character get his helmet secured in time
to survive the crash of the independence
the film's already perfect second half
would have benefited from oscar's wry
sense of wonder is there any talk of a
special edition
to correct this yes um
well i it would have been nice for oscar
um to uh to have you know
made it a little bit further at that
point in my career i was uh
you know i seldom made it to the third
act you know
anaconda i didn't even make it to the
middle of the second
you know armageddon um you know the
second act there so
that went on for a while till i till
they um
or until i was able to uh see the end
credits
thank you for indulging that i i'm sure
michael will appreciate it
oh so i listen i think your work in loki
is fantastic
uh what did you what surprised you about
actually
making this series and working with
marvel that perhaps you weren't
expecting
i think that you know early on sort of
the level of kind of secrecy
um that was um
you know not wanting people to see sort
of even
you know the wardrobe and the look uh
i really came to sort of appreciate when
i kind of you know marvel's fan base is
so
passionate that uh they really
you know put in a big effort to kind of
surprise
people and uh to kind of save it for
when it's um you know when it airs so
uh i thought that was kind of
interesting and cool because i hadn't
been a part of
something where you know there was that
degree of
um you know attention uh put on to
you know really trying to save it for
when uh
audiences could see it i think that fans
are really gonna respond to the stuff
with you and tom
just the long dialogue scenes are so
well done
um did you have a good enough time
making this that if they call you and
say we want to do a second season you'd
be like yeah sign me up
i'm ready yeah well you were talking
about those long scenes and they felt
long sometimes when we were doing we
were you know
worked on those for days and you wonder
oh will people have the patience will
this be compelling
you know seeing two people just sort of
you know sit across from one another but
um it seems like they turned out well
and i i had a great time working on it
you know it's one of those things that
um i think it's sort of like you said
about
um crashers it's you know have to come
up with a good story
i already got to stop there and i'm just
going to say seriously you did great
work on this series and fans are going
to love it
thank you